[Applause]
thank you so much for
[Applause]
I love you too
really
all right thank you for coming this is
our last show and so I know we will vac
January 19th to talk about all the mass
shootings and masturbating actors that
make America the greatest country in the
world they didn't gentleman yeah you
know what I need a break
I'm not gonna lie well I think we all
need a little break right I mean this
has been a tough year for America four
truths for women for potted plants I
don't even know where to start with the
harasser I watched Entertainment Tonight
last night it was just a half-hour of
Nancy O'Dell throwing up into a bucket
[Music]
but if there's any bright spot in it
down in Alabama where Roy Moore is and
you'll admit it that's quite a from
Alabama where Roy Moore is running for
the Senate on the Republican ticket his
opponent the Democrat in Alabama Doug
Jones is ahead in the polls Wow in
Alabama
and political experts are saying that
his recent surge is due to not [ __ ]
kids yeah that's where we are in America
yeah Roy Moore has nine accusers now and
Moore said he would not drop out Moore
had a press conference yesterday judge
Roy Moore he said we need he's not
dropping out cuz he said we need moral
value back in our country and then OJ
came up to discuss anger management Wow
these guys they got big balls they got
it given that yeah I mean all these
accusers are coming forward one girl
said that Roy Moore hit on her when she
was at the mall as you do when you're
the district attorney in your 30s so she
didn't give him her phone number so Roy
Moore called the principal of her school
who called her in and you know what his
what his excuses he said I don't
remember dating any girl without the
permission of her mother I'm a
chivalrous child molestin that's where
we in Alabama of course a high school
seniors a MILF you know that's
I mean I mean when I think of Alabama
back then I think of their horrendous
civil rights record but you know forget
the police dogs get the DA to stop
humping my leg and you know he was you
heard this Roy Moore was banned from the
mall too creepy for an Alabama mall
that's like being too fat for the Iowa
State Fair too high for Burning Man I
mean
and then there's another woman who came
forward who said she went to see Roy
Moore in his office in 1991 to sign some
custody papers and more grabbed her very
hard in the butt
she was 28 but more says in his defense
she looked much younger so you know Fox
News did not really wanted to talk too
much about the sexual harassment when it
was Roy Moore or Donald Trump or
everybody at Fox News and then Al
Franken came along yesterday right
very disturbing I was so shaken I called
Bill Cosby to see if it anything there
could calm me down as I'm sure you know
by now when I was on a USO tour in Iraq
in 2006 with Lian tweetIn he released a
picture where he's mock groping her
while she's sleeping not cool at all and
then he wrote a sketch where they were
kissing as a pretext to actually force a
kiss on her this is what she says so
Al's a friend but ow I got to tell you
if you write a comedy sketch were you Al
Franken
kiss a model and the next line of
dialogue isn't get off of me creepy it's
not comedy it's science fiction so he
he did a bad thing and the condemnation
has been universal which he deserves
what he doesn't deserve is to be lumped
in with Roy Moore or Kevin Spacey or
Harvey Weinstein or Donald Trump Donald
Trump calls his accusers liars
threatened to sue them did long rifts at
his rallies we would say that they were
too ugly for him to assault Plus with Al
Franken we're talking about one incident
Trump has 16 accusers Roy Moore has 9
rice more spent more time chatting up
young girls at the mall than Santa Claus
so how about another me to campaign
where it's I can tell too unlike things
apart me too I know the difference with
a man who once acted like a dick and a
man who is a dick me too
I know the difference between someone
who behaved like a high schooler and
someone who targeted high school alerts
me in overseas news but there is some
overseas I mean Trump got back from his
big 12 day trick did you see this his
speech to declare his 12 day Asian trip
a huge success a bit of tripping anybody
ever had they loved me more than Obama
over there and did you see this speech
yesterday oh my god he was racing
through it like nothing
I kept taking drinks of water did you
see that it he never actually fought in
Vietnam but he still came home with the
drug problem I don't understand
everybody made a big deal of him taking
the water you know what I don't care if
Trump drank water during his speech I
want to see if Trump can keep talking
when putting Putin takes a drink of
water